they are cutting open the mangled
remains of a passenger train to rescue
those who are trapped after yet another
Collision on India's underfunded rail
network
this Express train was carrying hundreds
of passengers from Kolkata to Chennai
when it derailed and a dozen of its
coaches overturned
as I stepped out of the trains bathroom
suddenly it tilted I lost my balance I
hold on to something I almost fell my
body tilted my slippers my bag
everything went topsy-turvy and people
started falling all over each other
as it lay on its side and those inside
tried to escape another collision and
then another this time an incoming
freight train crashing into the wreckage
there are many who have died and so many
injured Allah saved us today
hundreds of workers from the security
forces the national disaster rescue
force and fire services are involved in
certain rescue Nightfall has added to
the challenge the Prime Minister tweeted
distressed by the train accident in
odisha in this hour of grief my thoughts
are with the bereaved families neither
injured recovered soon
hospitals and districts have been put on
high alert rescue workers are racing
Against Time
and with each minute the chance of
finding someone alive is fading never
Lazarus Sky News Delhi